my name is Alicia Sheila I will talk
today about infants QL which is our new
platform for automated inference for
programmer and data analysts the
inference Gale platform is a software
project done in a research lab which
unlike software part is many other
research lab will persist over years and
is thus quite some team effort a bunch
of people contributing Vikash who was
the principal investigator in the group
which what we should be here today at
strange loop zane software engineering
lead in the front also here talk to me
or them
Harish Stella is doing our UX for us at
done a lot of the research behind the
theory behind this and Nick is a new
master student who contributes and Sarah
helps with civic use cases for the
infant scale platform so what we want to
do with infants QL is empowering
programmers and data analysts to do
probabilistic inference and we hope that
influenced scale helps them to do this
with a sequel like query language and
some automated inference engine based on
heuristic programming and the
probabilistic probing parent paradigm I
will talk a little bit about the
background of automated data modeling
and prolific programming I will give two
tutorials including live demos on
real-world data I will talk a little bit
about the limitations of the existing
inference key our prototype and our
current research and I will show a
real-world application one of the
real-world applications that we have in
our lab off insurance QL what is Pro
listing inference probabilistic
inference allows you to answer questions
with models oftentimes models about data
and examples for such questions are
given a data set of rental listings that
contains errors what are clean records
most likely to be or given data from a
wet lab experiment in biology for
example what is the probability
modifying a certain gene won't influence
any other genes and thus downstream
effects that we want to avoid given data
about cluster job run time maybe you
want to ask whether a certain job on the
x ester is likely to succeed and how
much cost will occur before doing so now
data and data science is a hard subject
and the graphic here that was conceived
by Andrew silver Andrew Conway there are
three axes and the three axis are
related to three domains and typical
backgrounds of the people try to use
that data one axis is intuition if your
domain expert and you look at data from
your domain you have an intuition about
what you want to find or what you should
find in the data the other axis is
automation if you have some coding
skills then you can produce data
pipelines that reproduce so that we
produce the same results over and over
again that can be used by other people
and that are basically sustainable if
you have statistic experience experience
then you know whether any conclusions
you draw from your data are supposed to
be valid and if you look at this Venn
diagram there are a number of danger
zones if you know how to hack and you
have knowledge about multivariate
statistics then oftentimes you don't
have to main knowledge because the to
learning the to probably takes on entire
career if you know about a domain and
you know about coding you're likely to
write traditional software and if you
don't know how to write software but
understand statistics and domain
expertise you're in trouble when more
complex methods are needed that require
more complicated pipelines the
consequence of this is that decision
makers oftentimes don't draw
results based on data analysis that I
put here on the slide this famous quote
by Churchill that he only believed
statistics that he doctored himself but
also a consultancies recently put out
some studies that suggested but over
half for exam of c-suite respondents
admit to discounting data analysis they
don't understand and that makes sense if
you look back at the Venn diagram that
we see there's plenty of reasons why a
decision-maker shouldn't believe their
data what is the solution
so Andrew Gelman famous statistician
from Columbia argues that statistics is
hard and we have to accept statistical
incompetence not as an aberration but as
a norm so training more and better
statisticians might not actually be the
solution and apparently according to
class tour it really which provides
another data point it's really not the
solution either you data scientists in
2017 was the most demanded job even
before DevOps engineer so just training
more might not work but then there's
this interesting sort of like dynamic
here where you know we have five million
developers we have 75,000 folks with
stats
grads it starts degrees and think around
the world roughly a hundred million
Excel Excel users do empirical inference
using Excel and what we're trying to do
with influenced QL is trying to mimic
what sequel did for business analytics
so sequel enable ten million people to
think about their data logically without
having to worried how its implementing
on the machine and if you go back
selected to the classic paper by Cod he
you know really summer summarized that
concisely in the first sentence of the
paper and it might be hard to read here
I'll just read it out loud as he says
future users of large data banks must be
protected having to know how the data is
organized in the machine and what we are
thinking about doing with inference QL
is doing the same thing for data
analytics and data science so our
aspiration
that's an aspiration not necessarily
realistic oh but then aspiration is to
enable 10 million people to think proble
is tickly and that includes programmers
spreadsheets users statisticians and
data scientists students an executive
and AI research and holistic programmers
all of those can use our tools per
program as an analyst can use inference
QL to solve inference problems using our
sequel like language or our closure API
spreadsheet users use inference based
use inference based data search and
filtering to understand what their data
will looks like that use case I have
witnessed personally with my bio
collaborators where we were on a call
with more than 15 biologic bio
collaborators who collaboratively sorted
columns to try to conclude which
experimental setting has which effect so
it's a real use case and again students
such as Asians and AI researchers we've
tried to sort like cover with inference
QL as well so as I said our solution is
a sequel like query language and
automated inference based on
probabilistic programming so what is
inference QL inference QL is a query
language and an automated inference
engine it uses probe allistic programs
written in closure via the meta prop
library meta promised about in-house the
probabilistic programming system we
provide baseline models automatically
generated with the cross cad model class
and our base DB system which we are
slowly deprecating but we had around for
six years in the lab and we're ongoing
with developing on it
we want to be we can customize models
using our four data scientist via the
growl virtual machine and inference we
are currently cross compiles to roughly
seven on kbf javascript we are intending
to release it under Apache 2.0 currently
it's in private beta so what is
probabilistic programming probabilistic
programs is based on two ideas one
puristic program at ballistic models can
be represented as code and two
operations on models can be represented
as meta programs doing something with
the programs that implement the rustic
models
what are these operations operations
include inference such as finding
probable values for latent variables
learning as I'm finding probable
parameters and structure given observed
data and querying answering what-if
questions
ranking data based on how surprising it
is and inferring unknown values with
calibrated confidence levels so prou
ballistic programming builds the
backbone of inference QL but we also
provide automated data modeling and we
do this via Bayesian synthesis of
probabilistic programs so the idea here
is that we start with a sparse data base
or data table
combine that with qualitative and
quantitative constraints if we want such
as if I have a data table and I want to
make sure that two columns are not
affect each other in the data table are
not related are treated independent
according to my model then we can
specify this we put both into the
synthesis engine and what the synthesis
engine spits out is a set of public
programs and assemble floristic programs
that model the data that we put in then
we can use a system like inference QL to
post queries against those pro stick
programs that we synthesized and out we
get answers answers for our questions
that we have about our data
so so much for theory but I brought a
case study that I will live demo in a
second and the case that is about
programmers from the 2017 Stack Overflow
survey now it's like Overflow every year
makes the users ask the users to fill
out a bunch of questions and we took a
subset of that data and I curated it for
the demo today and the idea here is that
again we have information in the world
about Stack Overflow all we have is
those survey answers can we get a pro
istic model program can be synthesized
it automatically so we can then ask
questions about that data and what this
like turistic probing is supposed to do
is it's supposed to virtually generate
new survey answers based on the data
that we learned based on the models that
we learned from the data that we've
synthesized from the data can we do that
automatically it turns out we can our
old base TB platform plus some new
extensions allows us in less than twenty
lines of code to synthesize ballistic
programs given only a data table and the
only constraints that I put in here
remember earlier I talked about of
qualitative and quantitative constraints
the only constraints I put in here in
this model is that certain columns are
supposed to be treated as numerical
variables and other ones are normally
nominal in this example we only have
four columns a data table four columns
because otherwise I wouldn't have fitted
it on a slide but the codes and the
calls to the base DB language and the B
call a query language wouldn't be
different what comes out is a program
like this this is a probabilistic
program that is written in closure and
runs with the meta Pub library and if
you execute it what you get is a new row
in this 4'o data table there four column
data table and it's the probe listing
model so you can
she write those meta programs those
query programs to get answer about the
data in the table from looking at that
model so those of you who have thought
about those problems before I might now
say well there's a technical challenge
here learning programs about your data
is the same as learning structure of a
model and people try to do this a few
years back for example in Bayesian
network structure learning and a bunch
of problems occurred and are not solved
for Bayesian network structure learning
basically today which is search over
structure is slow and unreliable it's
hard to include hidden variables it's
hard to apply to mix data types and it's
very difficult to combine with accurate
quantitative models if you wanted to
insert your own domain knowledge in form
of a quantitative model it's difficult
to get uncertainty over the model
structure and it's also hard for
ordinary users to ask questions but we
have new solutions to this problem so
instead of doing the old structure
search we use modern modern Montecarlo
inference on the cloud to get to
solutions and reasonable time we have a
nonparametric bayesian prior and models
that allow us to include hidden
variables models that we have researched
for years the mixed data type are
expressed using our own domain-specific
language that is part of inference QL
and we can include custom code and I
will life them or that later on and we
can get uncertainty via modern Monte
Carlo and inference QL allows you to
query those models via both spreadsheet
interface and a sequel interface so now
to the live demo
so I don't know how readable that is but
what we see here is data from this Stack
Overflow survey so every row in this
data table is a software developer or a
programmer who answered the survey and
every column is a certain question for
example that they do they know the best
shell do they know about Linux do they
know Java Arduino C++
what is their opinion about AI how many
years are decoding professionally what
do they earn
are they satisfied in their job and so
on so that's data from the real world
are we observed we can click on those
columns to visualize the data so might
be a little bit hard to read but if you
hover over it it's better so if you look
click at the the Linux column it's like
in this subset of the data 61 of the
records employed at the person they
didn't know didn't know Linux and 39 do
know Linux if you go for example to the
salary column click on that too you get
a histogram of the numerical salaries
one note about that histogram it's some
software development program as salaries
worldwide so there's this interesting
distribution now what we've just seen
you know you could do in Excel and I
told you before that oops that we can do
more and what I will demo now is that
because we have an underlying
probabilistic program that we learn from
this data we can just execute this
program to gain new virtual data virtual
survey answers based on the model that
we learn from from the original data in
order to save me the embarrassment of
making you all watch my typos I will
just copy the query
[Music]
so our query says select all from and
now here is a statement that's specific
to two inference Cal from generate
everything as an entire row from the
underlying model and stop after one new
data point has been generated if I run
this query we see in the bottom table
new data starts to show up it can run
this again every time one new data point
shows up we can change the limit and
generates a 100 data points over time so
that data is representing what we've
learned from the model so for example if
you click on this Linux column and these
from the real world data and the Linux
column from the observed from the verbs
founded from the virtually generated
survey answers you can tell that the
distribution aligns so what we learned
seems to be in line with the data that
was observed plus some minor uncertainty
so we see that we can generate motivated
new samples from the model that has been
generated given this data now if we
wanted to zoom in into a specific region
of the thing the model learned we can
tell this by modifying the query so we
can write generate all from model let me
just copy it again so and I'm gonna make
any silly mistakes generate all given
that Java is false so given that a
developer doesn't know Java
what should the other data look like
oops
let me clear what I generated before and
generate say 100 data points here and
now we get a hundred virtual survey
answers that are condition that are
conditioned on a developer knowing Java
you can use this and try to visualize
oops
and click that sorry what I meant to
show was visualizing that the
conditional distributions as in the
conditionally generated data here from
bash shell given that a user knows Java
so we can zoom in and what we learned
and that's a query language so you can
basically ask an infinite amount of
questions here so you could ask here
Chuck could ask you how about we want to
generate data given something knows Java
and they know say Linux oops
typo and we copy
yeah I forgot to write Linux equals true
so what we going to generate a state ax
for developers who don't know Java and
but do know Linux so all of Java is
false and Linux is true so we basically
see when we click at for example this
distribution that's the distribution of
somebody knowing bath she'll given given
that they know Linux but not Java so why
is this useful so first of all we can
use this to make statements about
missing data so I showed you how we can
generate new data conditioned and other
information so if I now wanted to know
like what user ate here what's his
opinion in the eye even though that
person didn't want to fill out the
survey I can click on that and get the
distribution of simulation simulated
data conditioned on all the other
information in that row so for this
particular user we are pretty certain
that they are excited about the
possibilities and not so worried about
the dangers of AI so you can use this to
fill in missing data you can also use
this to check how expected existing data
is so say I clicked on this user here
who doesn't know C++ which is getting
this distribution here the red line is
the actual observed value so we don't
know C++ and it turns out yeah that's
what we expect they shouldn't notice C++
given everything else in the data but
how about some this person here well for
them it turns out they actually know
Linux but all the other data in the row
would suggest that they shouldn't as in
like this is the
lucien for linux true and false and
while the person knows linux the data
suggests that they shouldn't by the way
the wiggling that you're seeing is
because we generate what is called
instars language Monte Carlo samples as
when we create a bunch of those newly
generated data to check how expected to
observe progress so this idea of
checking how expected observed is it's
quite interesting in the sense that we
can use this to detect unusual data so
let's do this let's for every single row
in our data table compute the
probability of seeing the observed
salary that this person has but not
taking to count any other data see if
you can read the query I haven't
included the given statement now so we
only look at the salary column let me
move the salary column and also delete
this or it'll not distract
so if I run this query what I get is a
bunch of probabilities that only say
okay not taking to come out any of
information what you know how probable
how expected is a certain salary and we
can visualize this by marking both of
them scrolling down and you see that
pretty no the salaries be normally
distributed obviously they're the
extreme values and the status set where
they earn more than two and a thousand k
they're not expected that's cool but not
that great you could do that with a
simple you know sequel statement as well
just by ordering it but we can also do
this again by taking to account all the
other information that we have about a
about a user so what we're now doing is
how it is trying to compute how expected
the salary is given every other all the
other information in every row so for
each row look at the seller salary that
that row has recorded look at everything
else and check whether it makes sense
let's run this you see the probabilities
change now let's also visualize it again
and suddenly the distribution looks
quite funny not as normal anymore and it
turns out that yes sort of like the
people who have extreme values still are
outliers there are hid those are here in
the bottom the x-axis is the salary by
the way and the y-axis the probability
if people can't read this however
there's also a person around here who is
in the top ten unlikely unexpected
values and but has a reasonable salary
and for other roles that salary is
perfectly fine as a bunch of you know
data in this regime but why is this
person special well let's look at it I
said before we can use inference gel to
search
existing data and the way we do this is
by simply sorting that column we saw the
entire data table according to column
and then let's pick out our friend who
has them sort of like average salary
I'm sway are they here 18 yeah thank you
so why are they not likely so it turns
out if you look at the survey answers
the person doesn't have any skill there
are not except they don't care about AI
which in the current day and time
apparently it's not good and the person
doesn't have any experience so all the
data that we have would suggest okay in
this distribution they should have less
so takeaway messages you can use this to
screen how unexpected
or an observed data a data point is in
the context of what the other
information is that we have about that
person now there's another way how we
can search our data which works
similarly but slightly different so
imagine the following use case I'm
looking for a Java Script developer so
somebody who knows Java Script I sought
to column according to put the true
things up first
[Music]
but I also want them to have you know
like reasonable amount of XP like quite
a ton of experience say so we want
somebody who's very experienced we want
them to leave a team so let's only take
people who have you know this person has
lots of experience who else 27 great
this person has a lot of experience oops
sorry
oh thank you so we provided a new column
in our data table our model wasn't
originally trained for that column in
terms of machine learning speak but we
can ask the model what's the probability
of the newly supplied label being true
given the rest of information that we
have because you have a learn the model
about all the other columns not the new
one that we just defined on the fly and
[Music]
but and then we want to see if we can
you know extrapolate from those four
data points on to sort of like other
data points other labels so what we
asked the model to do is generate a set
of predictions for all the other columns
and the first folks who come up all have
like reasonably fluent and no JavaScript
now I only have provided for labeled
examples and very little inference and I
have to say at this point we have
invested a zero point zero time and
optimizing the speed of any of this
so like all the parameters are tuned
down but that's not a problem but those
four wrong examples here I can just you
know also label them as false and then
ask the system to basically improve the
prediction I have ten minutes of time
I'm probably at half of my talk which is
not that great so
[Laughter]
I think I will move on great the other
tutorial that I want to talk about as
well talk about is one about earth
satellites and the data on this example
is coming from a citizen science project
the Union of Concerned Scientists people
who have observed satellites in the sky
and then collect data about this here's
an example row in the data table
everything that is red on the right is
missing so this data is heterogeneous as
in there is categorical values what is
the purpose was the user there are an
America variables and so on and they're
a bunch of Upsala actually I should go
and present mode again there are quite a
bunch of questions you can ask about
that data you could draw inferences
about new data as partially observed you
can screen the data for arrows anomalies
you can find similar satellites quantify
predictive value of information you can
fill in the missing values you can model
the patterns of missing news and so on
cool
the work flow is the same you basically
start with observations of the world
generate a formalistic program and have
this thing in our life demo oops so the
user interface pretty much the same only
that now our columns are are this data
inputted by by a by the citizen
scientist what is the purpose data about
of like the orbit perigee Apogee and
period minutes the type of orbit and so
on and we can you know play the same
game again and generate new data from
the model that we learned from this data
above
so let's generate 30 data points and
check how data lines from the
simulations to the virtual satellites
and the data that we've seen and I mean
if you could see like yeah the
simulations are act and not that great
the reason for that is that we only
looked at the data we didn't add any
information about the model no domain
knowledge whatsoever but we're not we
can fix that we can right-click on a
certain column say period minutes a
column about which we have information
and basically add information about how
that column should be generated given
other columns and we do this by adding
basically Kepler's laws and now I pop
maybe what we want to check is once we
add that in to our predictions and proof
so we set this we again epsilon generate
30 new data points
let's compare again this is the observed
data
and that's the newly generate data so
there's a little bit of an improvement
but not much so we can use this as sort
of like a way to evaluate our hypothesis
of whether that model improves okay I
have five minutes I guess limitations
about our current research we're trying
to find names how we describe our
prototype and I have to tell you that
this is a research prototype so it's
very very early it's developed by
students and some software engineers but
there's a reason why it's currently beta
we need better support for combining
more statistical symbolic and neural
models we want to do micro benchmarking
and performance engineering so the
queries run faster we want add support
for testing goodness-of-fit and we want
quantitative tests for sensitivity and
passivity for detecting for detecting
multi rate relationships and we want to
increase our query language to add
missing like sequel like functionality
like insert column which currently
doesn't really why I have one more
example application this is a real word
use case where we use this currently we
work on a DARPA project on synthetic
biology where the problem statement is
ok you look at an organism you have an
experimental set up you modify the
organism you have a wet lab environment
you want to know what happens inside the
organism but all you get is noisy
observations all you get is like what
they call RNA seek measurements so it's
unclear what happens inside the organism
if you knew what happened inside the
organism you could run an ordinary
analysis of the program and you would
get an idea about the mechanisms and the
dependencies that have generated your
noisy observations but again we don't so
the problem statement again is the same
we have a wet lab experiment the
biologist we work with produce tons of
data but it's unclear what goes on in in
in the data and our approach actually
produces accurate simulators for pretty
Dicky pretty tricky distributions what
we see here is an example where you have
the normalized read count of gene
expressions for two genes and we can see
that basically it's highly nonlinear but
our virtual simulations line up really
well with the observed data I have a
very quick live demo that I will just
show on this and we can basically that
that's basically showing what we do and
what we supply to biologists for in this
use case which is they want to
understand what gene is quote unquote
talkative as an if you modify certain
gene will it affect other genes can they
engineer that gene safely or can they
not because if gene is quote unquote
talkative that means there will be
downstream effect one gene expresses
another expresses another and you don't
know what happens and more often that
happens the more likely it is that the
cell that the organism dies because
unclear what happens down the line so
what the graph shows is a bunch of genes
and their predictive relationships and
the key takeaway from this demo is if
you change that to just linear
correlation which is best practice in
synthetic biology still all of the
relations disappear because our data is
so linear nonlinear and in fact it turns
out that our model in total variation
distance if you discretize the the the
numerical space is doing way better than
both a linear model and of multi rate
normal
and in fact if you fit a line just
between those two two two two genes it
doesn't really get it and the total
variation distance reflects that
okay the demo apparently was supposed to
happen here I already gave it to you
yeah collaborations our team is growing
the software is mature maturing and we
are looking for collaborations and
automated intelligence for example data
cleaning for streams of structured
records in industrial settings
performance modeling is something that
is interesting to us if you want to do
data-driven performance modeling please
reach out and crowdsource data labeling
creation it's also an interesting
subject using the query I demonstrated
on the JavaScript and and and experience
column in the stack of data for example
in terms of domain-specific
collaborations we already helping data
journalists search census data to direct
field journalism and we work with mental
health experts to improve mental health
questionnaires based on empirical data
the reason here being is if you want to
really diagnose a patient with mental
health issues what you had and theory to
do is you know expose them to ten twenty
questionnaires meaning you have to ask
them a thousand questions and that never
really works so they want us to look at
their data and understand sort of you
know what are the questions they should
really ask where are the predictive
relationships in terms of statistics
speak so thank you on our webpage one
more thing on our webpage there's a
sign-up form if you want to reach out
about collaborating and contributing
please do yeah thank you
[Applause]